This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the early hours of the morning when the air was heavy and the ticking clock ran slow, Randy Gardner would step out into his yard. He would stand beside the cactus's seat planted and listen to the cars that whiz by on Highway 54, which runs behind his home in San Diego. Standing in the moonlit shadows, he would call out in agony. I would go out on the back yard of three in the morning and scream my head off like a wild animal. Many people are familiar with the suffering Randy experienced. Insomnia. There's a lonely communion that binds those who plead with the gods
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在清晨空气沉重、时钟滴答走得很慢的时刻，兰迪·加德纳会走到他的院子里。他会站在种下的仙人掌座位旁，听着呼啸而过 54 号公路的汽车，这条公路穿过他在圣迭戈的家后方。站在月光下的阴影中，他会痛苦地呼喊。“我会在凌晨三点走到后院，像野兽一样放声尖叫。”许多人都熟悉兰迪所经历的痛苦。失眠。有一种孤独的共鸣，将那些向神明祈求的人紧紧连在一起。
at 3 o'clock in the morning. No one can help you. No one can make you feel better. No one can do anything. It's like you're going insane. But Randy also knew he was different from everyone else. Many years ago, as a teenager, he tempted those very same gods. His punishment, he understood, was payback. Thank you again. Have a lovely day.
在凌晨三点。没有人能帮得了你。没有人能让你感觉好一点。没有人能做任何事。这感觉就像你要发疯了。但兰迪也知道自己和所有人都不一样。许多年前，当他还是个青少年时，他曾向那些神明发起挑战。他明白，他的惩罚就是代价。再次感谢你。祝你过美好的一天。
I was in San Diego recently for a conference. I had some downtime, so I hopped in an Uber and headed to Randy's house. Hey! Are you Randy? Yeah, I'm Randy. Randy Shankar is so nice to meet you. So nice to meet you. How are you?
我最近去圣迭戈参加一个会议。我有一些空闲时间，于是我跳上一辆优步，直奔兰迪的家。嘿！你是兰迪吗？对，我是兰迪。兰迪，很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你。你好吗？
Randy Gardner greets me in the driveway of his home. He gives me a warm handshake and a smile. He's wearing a lemon colored shirt and sky blue shorts that set off his deep tan. He exudes Southern California charm. Man, you live in paradise. Well, it sits okay. Do you have bad weather events here?
兰迪·加德纳在他家的车道上迎接我。他给了我一个热情的握手和一个微笑。他穿着一件柠檬黄的衬衫和天蓝色的短裤，衬托出他古铜色的皮肤。他散发着南加州的魅力。天哪，你住在天堂里。嗯，这里还算过得去。这里有什么恶劣天气吗？
We have hotter than hell. It's a lot of flex we're doing. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Randy lives in a small green and white house Do you have bad weather events here? We have hotter than hell. What a flex we're doing. Randy lives in a small green and white house surrounded by sandy brown stucco homes. The backyard is next to a noisy freeway. Randy and his wife Ilona share their place with a 13-year-old Bengal cat, George. Sorry, what I meant was Prince George. We did not spoil him, he came that way.
我们这里热得要命。我们在疯狂炫耀呢。对，对，对。兰迪住在一个绿色相间的小房子里，周围是沙棕色的灰泥房屋。后院紧挨着一条吵闹的高速公路。兰迪和他的妻子伊洛娜和一只 13 岁的孟加拉猫乔治一起住在他们的地方。抱歉，我的意思是乔治王子。我们可没有宠坏他，他生来就是这样。
Randy and Ilona are now retired, which means lots of time to focus on George and their hobbies. These are photographs that I took. The walls are covered with some of his favorite shots, the golden gate in San Francisco, and stacked on the shelves are knickknacks and toys. At one point in the cross space I had over 500 puzzles. Oh my God. And you were a little bit... Our story really begins in 1963 when Randy moved to San Diego.
兰迪和伊洛娜现在退休了，这意味着有大量的时间来专注于乔治和他们的爱好。这些是我拍的照片。墙上挂满了最喜欢的一些照片，比如旧金山的金门大桥，书架上堆满了小摆设和玩具。我曾一度在杂物空间里拥有超过 500 个拼图。哦，天哪。而你有点……我们的故事实际上始于 1963 年，当时兰迪搬到了圣迭戈。
He was 17. It was the last in a long line of childhood moves. I'm the oldest of four siblings in a military family and my father traveled around so we were in different places every two years we lived somewhere else. In every town they lived in, Randy entered the science fair. I was kind of a science nerd when I was young. When we came to this town, San Diego, I thought boy, this is a big city.
他当时 17 岁。这是童年时期长途迁徙中的最后一次。我是军人家庭四个孩子中的老大，我父亲四处奔波，所以我们每两年就会去不同的地方，住在别的地方。在他住过的每一个城镇，兰迪都参加了科学博览会。我年轻时有点像个科学书呆子。当我们来到这个小镇圣迭戈时，我想，天哪，这是一座大城市。
If you wanted to win in San Diego, because I always got in San Diego, he'd have to pull out all the stops. There were 21 times and here come the Skyliners, since I don't have you. To understand the project he came up with, it's important to know something about the time. Rock and Roll was changing radio, and it wasn't just the songs that were gaining notice. It was the DJs playing them. The fabulous 40 of 1959, your hits for the year are Peter Tripp. One of them was Peter Tripp, a New York City DJ who hosted Your Hits of the Week on WMGM.
如果你想在圣迭戈取胜——因为我总是在圣迭戈——你就得使出浑身解数。有 21 次，天际线乐队来了，既然我没有你。为了理解他想出的这个项目，了解当时的背景很重要。摇滚乐正在改变广播，吸引注意力的不仅仅是歌曲。还有播放它们的 DJ。1959 年神话般的 40 首年度热门歌曲是彼得·特里普。其中一人是彼得·特里普，一位纽约市的 DJ，他在 WMGM 主持《本周热门》。
Peter plays an important part in our story. He wanted to stand out in the Disjockey world, and so in 1959 he came up with a stunt. He announced he was going to do a wake-a-thon to raise money for charity. He'd go eight days without sleep and be on display the entire time. On January 20th, 1959, Peter began broadcasting from a small glass studio in the middle of Times Square. Scientists were there to watch. For the next eight days, he hosted his show while fighting off sleep, preening it first, then yawning, eventually hallucinating. One thing he didn't do, sleep. Me, because it was at 7.14 pm on January 28th of 1959, and we played this record after heading straight away for 200 hours.
彼得在我们的故事中扮演着重要角色。他想在 DJ 世界中脱颖而出，于是在 1959 年想出了一个噱头。他宣布他将举办一场马拉松清醒活动来为慈善机构筹集资金。他将连续八天不睡觉，并且全程接受展示。1959 年 1 月 20 日，彼得开始在时代广场中央的一个小型玻璃录音室进行广播。科学家们在一旁观察。在接下来的八天里，他一边与睡意作斗争，一边主持节目，先是整理仪容，然后打哈欠，最后出现幻觉。他唯一没做的事就是睡觉。我，因为那是在 1959 年 1 月 28 日下午 7 点 14 分，我们在连续坚持了 200 小时之后播放了这张唱片。
Here are the bill, though, that I've had it. Peter's tongue invited others. A few months later, Adijay and Honoluluolulu Tom Rounds raised the stakes by going 260 hours, more than 10 days without sleep. Intentional sleep deprivation was apparently like the ice bucket challenge for DJs in the 1960s. 17-year-old Randy Gardner, looking to make his mark on the science fair in a new city, wasn't
不过，账单就在这里，我已经受够了。彼得的举动引来了其他人。几个月后，檀香山的 DJ 汤姆·朗兹将赌注提高到了 260 小时，即连续 10 多天不睡觉。故意剥夺睡眠显然就像 20 世纪 60 年代 DJ 们的冰桶挑战一样。17 岁的兰迪·加德纳想要在一个新城市的科学博览会上留下自己的印记，他对这些壮举并不
impressed by these feats. Eight days without sleep, ten days without sleep, big deal, he thought. You don't need a lot of sleep. You don't need sleep. It was, that was the thinking back in the 60s and that's the thinking that I had. Randy decided to show up the showman. He decided he was going to go without sleep for 264 hours. Exactly 11 days.
印象深刻。八天不睡觉，十天不睡觉，有什么了不起的，他想。你不需要很多睡眠。你不需要睡眠。这就是 60 年代的想法，也是我当时的看法。兰迪决定给这个作秀者一点颜色看看。他决定连续 264 小时不睡觉。整整 11 天。
And when I said, let's go 11 days, I wasn't even thinking about any negative things. I was thinking, this really isn't that big of a deal. You know, when it's over, you catch up, you get your sleep and you go right on by. Even as a teenager, Randy knew that he had a special skill that made him different. I'm a very determined person, and when I get things under my crawl, I can't let it go until there's some kind of a solution. He recruited two of his friends, Bruce McAllister and Joe Marciano, to help him stay awake. If you're on your own, you're going to succumb. You're going to fall asleep.
当我说，让我们坚持 11 天时，我甚至没有考虑任何负面事情。我在想，这其实没什么大不了的。你知道，当它结束时，你补个觉，睡个觉，然后继续前进。即使在少年时期，兰迪也知道自己有一种与众不同的特殊技能。我是一个非常坚定的人，当我把事情抓在手里时，除非找到某种解决办法，否则我是绝不会放手的。他招募了他的两个朋友布鲁斯·麦卡利斯特和乔·马尔西亚诺来帮他保持清醒。如果你靠自己，你就会屈服。你会睡着。
Christmas break was coming up, and Randy and his friends decided it was the perfect time to break the world record for going without sleep. The first two days were easy. He stayed away from beds and tried to stand as much as he could. But on day three, I noticed that in the morning I was really nauseous and this went on for just about the entire rest of the experiment. And that's when I stumbled
圣诞假期即将来临，兰迪和他的朋友们决定这是打破不睡觉世界纪录的最佳时机。头两天很容易。他远离床铺，尽量多站着。但到了第三天，我注意到早上我真的开始恶心了，这种情况几乎持续了实验的整个剩余部分。也就是在那时，我偶然
on eating citrus for some reason. Tangerines or oranges seem to take the nausea away. So your friends, of course, were keeping tabs on you, but they weren't actually accompanying you in the experiment. So what happened? Was one keeping tabs on you but they weren't actually accompanying you in the experiment so what happened was one of them did you have a rotation system and one of them was always up with you? That exactly was a rotation system where one would be with me and the other would be sleeping or if it was in the daytime they both be with me obviously. Soon the stunt was attracting television reporters and that was a good thing because that kept me awake. You know, you're dealing with these people and their cameras and their questions.
不知为何开始吃柑橘类水果。橘子或橙子似乎能消除恶心。所以你的朋友们当然一直在关注你，但他们并没有真正陪着你做实验。那么发生了什么？是一直有人关注你，但他们并没有真正陪着你做实验，所以发生的事情是其中一个人吗？你们有一个轮流值班系统，其中一个人总是陪着你吗？完全是这样，有一个轮流系统，一个人会陪着我，另一个人在睡觉，或者如果是白天，他们俩显然都会陪着我。很快，这个噱头就吸引了电视记者，这是件好事，因为这让我保持清醒。你知道，你要应付这些人以及他们的摄像机和问题。
Did you start to feel like your mental faculties were slipping? That it was harder to answer questions, it was harder to remember something to formulate a phrase or a sentence? That happened pretty soon. to answer questions, it was harder to remember something to formulate a phrase or a sentence. That happened pretty soon. That was, that started maybe day four or five and it just kept going downhill. I mean, it was crazy where you, you couldn't remember things. It was almost like an early Alzheimer's thing brought on by lack of sleep. The early hours of the morning were hardest.
你是否开始觉得自己的精神机能正在衰退？回答问题变得更难了，记住某些事情、組織一个短语或句子也变得更难了？这很快就发生了。回答问题，记住某些事情、組織一个短语或句子变得更难了。这发生得相当快。那是，这大概从第四天或第五天开始，然后就一路走下坡路。我的意思是，这太疯狂了，你記不住事情。这几乎就像是因为缺乏睡眠而引发的早期阿尔茨海默症。清晨是最难熬的。
Everything was closed, everyone was asleep. Randy remembers visiting the local jail. Why did he go to the jail? I don't know. Maybe because it was open at three in the morning. We never close. A few days into the wakeathon, a sleep researcher from Stanford University showed up. His name, and this may feel like a pun to some of you,
万物闭门，人人入睡。兰迪记起自己去过当地的监狱。他为什么要去监狱？我不知道。也许是因为它在凌晨三点开门。我们永不打烊。在清醒马拉松开始几天后，来自斯坦福大学的一位睡眠研究人员出现了。他的名字，对你们中的一些人来说可能觉得像是一个双关语，
was William Dement. And he got a he rented a car convertible. We drove around that. So we had a really good time when Dr. Dement came down. That really helped me because that was like a fresh of something different and new to keep me going. I understand that Dr. Dement also played a lot of games with you. He, besides sort of doing sort of psychological tests, he actually played various sort of
叫威廉·德门特。他租了一辆敞篷车。我们开着它到处跑。所以当德门特博士来的时候，我们玩得很开心。这真的帮了我大忙，因为那就像是一股清新、不同且全新的活力，让我能够坚持下去。我听说德门特博士还陪你玩了很多游戏。除了做一些心理测试外，他实际上还和你玩了各种
sports with you, is that right? We did a lot of pinball. How do you do? I did good. I think I beat him most of the time. Actually, Randy won all the time. Physically, I didn't have any problems. Not walking or throwing the basketball around or playing the pinball games, but the
运动，是这样的吗？我们玩了很多弹珠机。你玩得怎么样？我玩得很好。我想我大部分时间都赢了他。事实上，兰迪一直都在赢。身体上，我没有任何问题。无论是走路、投篮还是玩弹珠机，但
metal part is what went downhill. The longer I stayed awake, the more irritable I got. I had a very short fuse on day 11. I remember snapping at reporters. They were asking me these questions over and over and over and I was just, I was a brat. On January 8th, 1964, Randy broke the world record for going without sleep.
精神部分却走下坡路。我醒着的时间越长，我就越暴躁。我在第 11 天时脾气变得非常暴躁。我记得我对记者发火。他们一遍又一遍、没完没了地问我这些问题，而我当时真是个乳臭未干的小鬼。1964 年 1 月 8 日，兰迪打破了不睡觉的世界纪录。
He'd gone 11 days, 264 hours without drifting off. There was only one way to celebrate. He was whisked off to a naval hospital where researchers kept an eye on him and he went to sleep. How long did you sleep? I slept just over 14 hours. I remember when I woke up I was groggy but not any groggy than a normal, normal person. And did you find that over the next several days or weeks you needed extra sleep? No, not at all.
他已经有 11 天、264 小时没有合眼了。只有一个办法可以庆祝。他被迅速送到一家海军医院，研究人员在那里监视着他，然后他入睡了。你睡了多久？我睡了刚好超过 14 小时。我记得当我醒来时，我感到昏昏沉沉，但并不比一个正常人更昏昏沉沉。你发现自己在接下来的几天或几周里需要额外的睡眠吗？不，完全没有。
I went right back to the regular mode and everything was fine. Strange, isn't it? Randy's sleep project earned him and his friends first place in the 10th annual Greater San Diego Science Fair. It also ushered in a lifetime of fame. This is sound from the popular 1960s TV game show to tell the truth. The show brings together four celebrity panelists.
我马上回到了正常的作息模式，一切都很好。很奇怪，不是吗？兰迪的睡眠项目为他和他的朋友们赢得了第十届大圣迭戈科学博览会的第一名。这也开启了一生的名气。这是 20 世纪 60 年代流行电视游戏节目《说实话》中的声音。该节目汇集了四位名人嘉宾。
I'm Poston, Aggie Cass. The panelists face three people who all claim to be the same person. What is your name, please? My name is Randy Gardner. My name is Randy Gardner. My name is Randy Gardner. The panelists have to guess which one is the real Randy.
我是波斯顿，阿吉·卡斯。嘉宾们面对三个人，他们都声称自己是同一个人。请问你叫什么名字？我叫兰迪·加德纳。我叫兰迪·加德纳。我叫兰迪·加德纳。嘉宾们必须猜出哪个才是真正的兰迪。
On the show, the real Randy Gardner is number two. Number two, how long did you sleep the minute you were through with the 11 days and nights? Fourteen hours and 43 minutes. And did you feel like Clark Kent? He wears dark, haundering glasses, his hair swoops to the left, he soft-spoken and direct when answering questions. Most of the panelists figured out that this Randy was the real Randy. I've heard it's an average ambiguity because he looks asleep-y.
节目中，真正的兰迪·加德纳是 2 号。2 号，当你度过那 11 天和 11 夜的最后一分钟时，你睡了多久？14 小时 43 分钟。你觉得自己像克拉克·肯特吗？他戴着一副深色、摇晃的眼镜，头发向左偏分，回答问题时语气温和、直截了当。大多数嘉宾都看出这个兰迪才是真正的兰迪。我听说这是一个平均模糊度，因为他看起来像是在睡觉。
I mean, carlaw. That's not too highly spreader as reason number two, one for number two. Over the next decade, Randy Gardner's life took different turns. He worked in horticulture, took a stab at photography, and finished up his career working as a stock trader. But whatever he did, his teenage accomplishment stayed with him. I'm some kind of a Bruce Springsteen in the sleep world. It's a very strange feeling.
我的意思是，卡劳。这作为 2 号的理由并不算太高，2 号投一票。在接下来的十年里，兰迪·加德纳的生活发生了各种转变。他从事过园艺工作，尝试过摄影，最后以股票交易员的身份结束了他的职业生涯。但无论他做什么，他十几岁时的成就一直伴随着他。我是睡眠界的布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀。这是一种非常奇怪的感觉。
Plenty of people have tried to do what Randy Gardner did, go days on end without sleeping. You can find clips of all their adventures on YouTube. It's Sunday afternoon right now, and tonight's day one of going without sleep for the next week. I'm about to stay up for three days. This is going to be the hardest challenge I've ever done. But if you're looking to set a new record for going without sleep, I'm quite stuck.
许多人都试图做兰迪·加德纳做过的事，连续几天不睡觉。你可以在 YouTube 上找到他们所有冒险经历的剪辑。现在是星期天下午，今晚是接下来一周不睡觉的第一天。我打算熬夜三天。这将是我做过最难的挑战。但如果你想创造一项不睡觉的新纪录，我完全卡住了。
I don't know what you're going to do. I'm just really going to. It's only been. You're out of luck. The Guinness Book of World Records has eliminated the category, citing the health dangers of severe sleep loss. That's right. This is UC Berkeley Neuroscientist Matthew Walker. And I think it's important to keep in mind, by the way, that Guinness does seem to deem it acceptable for a man, I believe it was Felix Baumgartner, to ascend to the very outer reaches of Earth's atmosphere in a capsule in a space suit, get out of that capsule and then free fall back down to Earth, breaking the sound barrier with his body traveling at well over 1000
我不知道你要做什么。我真的只是要去。才刚开始。你太倒霉了。《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》已经取消了这一类别，理由是严重睡眠不足带来的健康危险。没错。这是加州大学伯克利分校的神经科学家马修·沃克。我认为记住这一点很重要，顺便说一句，吉尼斯似乎认为一个男人——我相信那是费利克斯·鲍姆加特纳——乘坐太空衣胶囊升至地球大气层的最外层边缘，从胶囊中出来然后自由落体回地球，用他的身体以远超每小时 1000
kilometers per hour. That deemed as okay to do. Sleep deprivation, because of its deathly consequences, no longer. So I hope that frames the disease-related risk that Guinness rightfully recognizes regarding insufficient sleep. Matthew Walker calls himself a sleep diplomat. He spent more than 20 years studying the topic and he's written a book titled Why We Sleep. If your idea of being sleep deprived as days on end without
公里的速度突破音障，这样做是可以接受的。睡眠剥夺，由于其致命的后果，则不再被接受。所以我希望这能衬托出吉尼斯正确认识到的关于睡眠不足的与疾病相关的风险。马修·沃克称自己为睡眠外交官。他花了 20 多年的时间研究这个课题，并写了一本名为《为什么要睡觉》的书。如果你的睡眠不足概念是连续几天没有
enough rest, Matthew says, think again, even just the smallest amount of insufficient sleep we seek health consequences. And I think perhaps, you know, one of the best examples of that small perturbation Is the one of the largest sleep experiments ever done? It's been performed on 1.6 billion people It happens twice a year and it continues to happen. It's called daylight savings time and In the spring when we lose an hour of sleep, we see a subsequent 24% increase in heart attacks. In the fall, when we gain an hour of sleep opportunity, there is a 21%
足够的休息，马修说，再想想吧，即使只是极少量的睡眠不足也会带来健康的后果。我想也许，你知道，其中最好的一个例子就是那个微小的扰动，就是有史以来最大的睡眠试验之一？它在 16 亿人身上进行，每年进行两次，并且还在继续进行。这被称为日光节约时间，在春天当我们失去一小时睡眠时，我们随后会看到心脏病发作率增加 24%。在秋天，当我们获得一小时的睡眠机会时，心脏病发作率会下降 21%
decrease in heart attacks. So that's how fragile our brain and body can be to even just the smallest fluctuations of sleep. So we don't have to go to the Randy Gardner extreme of eleven days. Just one hour of sleep is all that it takes to show these types of demonstrable consequences in terms of ill health. If you do the math, eleven days times eight recommended hours of sleeper night, that's 88 hours of sleep that Randy missed. When he finally went to bed, he slept only 14 hours.
。因此，我们的宝贵大脑和身体对于哪怕最微小的睡眠波动也是如此脆弱。所以我们不必达到兰迪·加德纳十一天那样的极端。仅仅一小时的睡眠就足以在身体健康方面显示出这种明显的后果。如果你算一下，11 天乘以每晚推荐的 8 小时睡眠，也就是兰迪缺少的 88 小时睡眠。当他最终上床睡觉时，他只睡了 14 个小时。
The human brain is not capable of getting back all of the sleep that it has lost. So sleep in this regard is not like the bank, you can't accumulate a debt and then pay it off at some later point in time. There isn't a credit system in the brain or the body. And we can ask by the way, why isn't there something like that? Wouldn't that be wonderful? And there is precedent there, that sells. So there were times in evolution when we would have feast and there were times when there was famine. And we designed a system to come up and store that caloric credit, and so that we could spend it when there was a debt. There may be a reason our bodies don't do this. The right analogy to sleep might not be eating, but breathing. You can't say, For a long time, Randy simply passed in the celebrity that his stunt had brought him.
人类的大脑无法找回它失去的所有睡眠。所以在这一点上，睡眠不像银行，你不能积累一笔债务，然后在以后的某个时间点偿还它。大脑或身体里没有信用系统。顺便我们可以问，为什么没有类似的东西呢？那不是很好吗？而且是有先例的，那就是细胞。所以进化时期有时会有盛宴，有时会有饥荒。我们设计了一个系统来储存热量信贷，以便在我们有债务时可以消费。我们的身体不这样做的原因可能是有道理的。对于睡眠来说，正确的类比可能不是吃，而是呼吸。你不能说，长久以来，兰迪只是沉浸在特技带给他的名气中。
He'd found a way to cheat sleep. Life was good for him and his wife, Ilona. The focus of our life is pretty much George. George the cat, that teenage Bengal. Randy and Ilona love George. I don't know much about cats, but apparently, Bengals have the personality of a dog. They fetch a cat that fetches. Are you serious?
他找到了欺骗睡眠的方法。他和妻子伊洛娜的生活很美好。我们生活的主要焦点基本上是乔治。猫乔治，那只十几岁的孟加拉猫。兰迪和伊洛娜非常爱乔治。我对猫了解不多，但显然，孟加拉猫有着狗的性格。它们会捡回东西，一只会捡东西的猫。真的吗？
He doesn't do it much anymore. Listening to Randy and Ilona, ooze with affection for George is very sweet. When I came to visit, Ilona was getting ready to take George to the vet. They're very meticulous about his health. That's partly because, a decade ago, there was another cat in Randy and Ilona's life. She died of a tongue cancer, and I was so upset that theets didn't catch it, that they never looked in her mouth to find this tumor that they blamed every other thing. And then she died, and I was so racked with guilt, which is stupid. You know, I would never do that. Now you have to move forward. You can't go back. But I didn't then. And I think that's what triggered it.
他现在不怎么这样做了。听着兰迪和伊洛娜对乔治倾注的喜爱非常甜蜜。我来拜访时，伊洛娜正准备带乔治去看兽医。他们对他的健康非常一丝不苟。部分原因是，十年前，兰迪和伊洛娜的生活中还有另一只猫。她死于舌癌，我非常沮丧，因为兽医没有发现它，他们从不看看她的嘴来发现这个他们归咎于其他所有事情的肿瘤。然后她死了，我充满了负罪感，这太蠢了。你知道，我绝不会那样做。现在你必须向前看。你不能回头。但我当时没有。我认为这就是导火索。
The it, Randy's referring to, is that I would go out in the backyard at three in the morning and scream my head off like a wild animal. Is insomnia. About ten years ago, I stopped sleeping. I could not sleep. I would lay in bed for five, six hours sleep, maybe 15 minutes, and wake up again. I kept thinking, well, this will change because it seems to me that eventually, if you don't get enough sleep, your body will just say, we're going to sleep,
兰迪所指的“它”，就是我会走到后院在凌晨三点像野兽一样放声尖叫。就是失眠。大约十年前，我停止了睡眠。我无法入睡。我在床上躺五、六个小时，睡大约 15 分钟，然后又醒来。我一直认为，嗯，这会改变的，因为在我看来，最终如果你睡眠不足，你的身体就会说，我们要去睡觉了，
but it never happened. The man who conquered sleep was now begging for a full night's rest. That's why I keep calling this some, some karmic payback for, you know, my body going, okay, buddy. Yeah, okay, 11 days without sleep. And you know, damn, you need sleep. Well, let's try this out for size. Randy says going without sleep changed him. And everybody thought I was some kind of
但这从未发生。那个征服了睡眠的人现在却在乞求一个完整的夜间休息。这就是为什么我一直把这称为某种业报的报应，为了，你知道的，我的身体在说，好吧，老兄。好吧，连续 11 天不睡觉。你知道，该死的，你需要睡眠。好吧，让我们试试这个尺码。兰迪说不睡觉改变了他。每个人都以为我是某种
There's all kinds of ways to go to sleep. They say, you know watch television Read a book and I'm thinking you know if you can't sleep in the first place reading a book isn't gonna put you to sleep I got news for you. I don't know where they came up with that. What read a book? Watch TV. No, no, no, no If you have that kind of a serious problem, you're done. Day in and day out, for years on end, Randy began to feel the way he'd felt at the end of his sleep stunt. Except this time, there were no TV cameras, no reporters, no prizes. I was awful to be around. Everything upset me.
有各种各样的方法可以入睡。他们说，你知道，看电视、读一本书，而我想，你知道，如果你一开始就睡不着，读一本书是不会让你入睡的，我得告诉你。我不知道他们是怎么想出这个主意的。读一本书？看电视？不，不，不，不，如果你有那种严重的问题，你就完了。日复一日，年复一年，兰迪开始感到他在睡眠特技结束时的那种感受。只是这一次，没有电视摄像机，没有记者，没有奖品。周围的人都觉得我很糟糕。每件事都让我心烦意乱。
It was like a continuation of what I did 50 years ago. We don't know what triggered Randy's insomnia, but there's some anecdotal evidence that prolonged sleeplessness can really mess up the brain. Remember Peter Tripp? You're here for the year I'm Peter Tripp. The radio DJ who inspired Randy with his wickathon, here's psychiatrist Floyd Cornelison,
这就像是我 50 年前所做事情的延续。我们不知道是什么引发了兰迪的失眠，但有一些轶事证据表明，长期的失眠确实会搞砸大脑。还记得彼得·特里普吗？年度热门人物，我是彼得·特里普。那个以他的清醒马拉松激励了兰迪的电台 DJ，这里是精神病学家弗洛伊德·科内利森，
who monitored Peter, speaking on the television series, Secrets of Sleep. The man I saw the first morning that he began this, when he was waving at everybody through the class one's and smiling and laughing and joking with us, after the 200 hours had become a change in the visual. In the months that followed, trips seemed unable to recover his center of gravity.
他曾监控过彼得，在电视系列剧《睡眠的秘密》中发言。我看到他开始这个活动的第一个早晨，当他在玻璃窗后向所有人挥手微笑并和我们开玩笑时，200个小时后，视觉上发生了变化。在接下来的几个月里，特里普似乎无法恢复他的重心。
He fought with his boss and lost his job. He ended up as a salesman, drifting from time to time across America. Those that knew him well were convinced that those eight days without sleep had left him permanently damaged. So some of that might have been hyperbole. Still, roundly things, what happened to Peter was real, and his age might have been a factor. That's why I don't think you can do this kind of thing unless you're 17 or in that age group.
他与老板争吵并失去了工作。他最终成了一名推销员，断断续续地漂泊在美国各地。那些非常了解他的人确信，那八天不睡觉让他受到了永久性的损害。因此，其中一些可能有些夸张。尽管如此，兰迪认为，彼得身上发生的事情是真实的，他的年龄可能是一个因素。这就是为什么我认为除非你 17 岁或处于那个年龄段，否则你不能做这种事。
I know I couldn't do it now, and I wouldn't do it now, because I have more sense. After a decade of insomnia in his 60s, Randy finally made an uneasy piece with sleep. He's regained the ability to drift off, but only for about six hours a night, and it's required sacrifice. I love drinking tea. And to this day, I can't drink tea because I'm afraid I won't be able to sleep at night. You have to have sleep.
我知道我现在做不到，我也不会现在做，因为我更有理智了。在 60 多岁经历十年的失眠后，兰迪终于与睡眠达成了某种不安的妥协。他重新获得了入睡的能力，但每晚只能睡大约六个小时，而且需要作出牺牲。我喜欢喝茶。直到今天，我仍然不敢喝茶，因为我害怕晚上会睡不着觉。你必须有睡眠。
It's as important as I call it the big three. Water, food, sleep. You've got to have them, all of them. I call it the big three, water, food, sleep. You gotta have them, all of them. Randy Gardner, the man who conquered sleep, is now terrified of going a night without it. After the break, we dive deeper into the science of sleep with neuroscientist Matthew Walker.
它和我说的大三样一样重要。水，食物，睡眠。你必须拥有它们，全部都要有。我称它为大三样，水，食物，睡眠。你必须拥有它们，全部都要有。兰迪·加德纳，这个征服了睡眠的人，现在却害怕度过一个不眠之夜。休息之后，我们将与神经科学家马修·沃克一起深入探讨睡眠科学。
If we didn't need eight hours of sleep and we could survive on six, Mother Nature would have done away with 25% of our sleep time millions of years ago. Because when you think about it, sleep is an idiotic thing to do. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is NPR.
如果我们不需要八个小时的睡眠，靠六个小时就能生存，大自然在数百万年前就会剥夺我们 25% 的睡眠时间了。因为当你仔细想想，睡觉是一件极其愚蠢的事情。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是美国国家公共电台。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Matthew Walker is a professor of neuroscience and psychology at the University of California at Berkeley. He studies sleep and he's the author of the book, Why We Sleep. I started our conversation by asking him to tell me a story he describes in his book. It's about a pianist who relied on sleep for his creative process. Yeah, I was giving a public lecture on sleep. And this wonderful, sort of, distinguished looking gentleman with a fantastic kindly face walked to me, stressing this great to tweed suit. And he said, I'm a pianist and I was fascinated by what you were saying about sleep and how active a brain state it is. And I wanted
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。马修·沃克是加州大学伯克利分校的神经科学和心理学教授。他研究睡眠，并且是《为什么要睡觉》一书的作者。我开始我们的对话时，请他讲一个他在书中描述的故事。那是关于一位依赖睡眠来进行创作过程的钢琴家的故事。对，我当时在做关于睡眠的公众演讲。而这位美妙的、看起来颇有绅士风度、有着一张极其慈祥面孔的先生走到我面前，身穿着这套漂亮的粗花呢西装。他说，我是一名钢琴家，我对你所说的关于睡眠以及它是一种多么活跃的大脑状态非常着迷。我想
to tell you that there are times when I will be trying to learn a new piece and I just can't get it. And I get frustrated, I make the same mistake at the same place each and every time. And I'll sometimes play late into the evening and I will walk away continuing to be frustrated. Have a night of sleep. And then when I come back and I sit down the next morning, I can just play perfectly. And what he was suggesting perhaps was that it wasn't practice that made perfect. It was practice with a night of sleep that made perfect. I want to run two other examples by you, both of which seem to suggest that remarkable things happen to us while we're sleeping. I understand the guitarist Keith Richards from Rolling Stones kept his instrument and
告诉你的是，有时当我试图学习一首新曲子时，我就是学不会。我感到沮丧，每次都在同一个地方犯同样的错误。我有时会弹到深夜，然后离开时依然充满沮丧。度过一夜的睡眠。然后当我第二天早上回来坐下时，我就能完美地弹奏了。他所暗示的也许并不是熟能生巧。而是练习加上一夜的睡眠才成就了完美。我想跟你探讨另外两个例子，这两个例子似乎都表明，当我们在睡觉时，非凡的事情会发生在我们身上。据我了解，滚石乐队的吉他手基斯·理查兹把他的乐器和
a recorder by his bed, and he did it in case inspiration struck while he was asleep. Did it ever happen? It did. He would have this tape recorder and he would have his guitar and he would have his whilst else around in the bedroom at the time. And one morning he woke up and the tape had recorded all the way to the end. And he didn't remember anything about that night. So he rewound the tape and he played it and he says, and this is in his autobiography, there was almost this sort of ghostly vision of him strumming the chords to satisfaction.
一个录音机放在床边，他这样做是为了以防在睡觉时灵感袭来。这真的发生过吗？确实发生过。他会有这个录音机，他会有他的吉他，还有他当时在卧室里的威士忌。一天早晨他醒来，磁带一直录到了最后。他不记得那天晚上的任何事情了。于是他倒回磁带并播放了它，他说，这是在他的自传里，几乎有一种幽灵般的幻象，是他正在弹奏《Satisfaction》的弦音。
Arguably the most popular Rolling Stone song ever and he said he created that classic guitar riff from his sleep. It was a dream inspired musical piece of creativity, followed by about 42 minutes of snoring. Lots of scientific discoveries, though, to have been birthed by way of dream sleep inspired creativity. Speaking of scientific discoveries, I understand there's a connection between sleep and the discovery of the periodic table. Demetri Mendelayev was trying to understand how all of the known elements in the universe fit together, and it was his obsession for years, and he struggled and
可以说是滚石乐队有史以来最受欢迎的歌曲，他说他从睡眠中创作出了那个经典的吉他连复段。这是一首由梦境激发的音乐创意作品，随后大约有 42 分钟的鼾声。不过，许多科学发现似乎也是通过梦境睡眠激发的创造力而诞生的。说到科学发现，我听说睡眠和周期表的发现之间存在联系。德米特里·门捷列夫正试图了解宇宙中所有已知元素是如何组合在一起的，这是他多年的痴迷，他苦苦挣扎，
he couldn't figure it out, he would create playing cards with all of the different elements and he would deal them to see if he could find some equation by way of which they all fit together. And apparently Sir The Stry goes, February 17th, 1869, he fell asleep, exhausted, frustrated, couldn't figure it out. And that in his sleeping brain, he started to realize how all of these swirling elemental ingredients could actually snap together in this sort of what he described as a divine grid. And he woke up and he pinned down this remarkable table, the table that we now call the periodic table of elements, and he noted that he made just perhaps one or two changes. Matthew says there are two types of sleep. Rapid eye movement
却无法弄明白，他会制作印有所有不同元素的扑克牌，并把它们发出去，看看能否找到某种方程让它们全部组合在一起。显然，正如这个故事所说，1869 年 2 月 17 日，他精疲力竭、满心沮丧地睡着了，还是没能弄明白。正是在他睡眠的大脑中，他开始意识到所有这些旋转的元素成分实际上是如何在一个他所描述的神圣网格中组合在一起的。他醒来后写下了这个非凡的表格，也就是我们现在所说的元素周期表，他指出他可能只做了一两处修改。马修说睡眠有两种类型。快速眼动
sleep, also known as REM. This is when we dream. Then there's non-rappad eye movement sleep or non-rem. And those two types of sleep actually play out in this wonderful battle for brain domination throughout the night. And that cerebral war is one and lost every 90 minutes and then replayed every 90 minutes to produce what we call a sleep cycle. And you go down into non-rhym sleep first and then you go up into REM sleep and then you repeat the cycle. You say that non REM sleep might be implicated or involved in cementing memories and that
睡眠，也称为 REM。这就是我们做梦的时候。然后是非快速眼动睡眠或非快速眼动（non-rem）。这两种睡眠实际上在整夜为了争夺大脑统治权而进行着精彩的战斗。这场脑力大战每 90 分钟胜负交替一次，然后每 90 分钟重演一次，从而产生我们所说的睡眠周期。你会先进入非快速眼动睡眠，然后上升到快速眼动睡眠，接着重复这个循环。你说非快速眼动睡眠可能与巩固记忆有关或参与其中，并且
there's a popular song that might get it this idea. Hello, darkness, my old friend. I've come to talk with you again. So Matthew, what does Simon and Garfunkel get right about 9 Ramsley? It is prophetic wisdom of the most remarkable kind. We imprint information during the day. We sort of that seed is planted there within the brain during the day. In other words, we learn information. But we also know that that vision that was planted in the brain still remains in the sound of silence, in this, in the dark of night, and it's there that specifically deep non-rem sleep
有一首流行歌曲可能抓住了这个想法。你好，黑暗，我的老朋友。我又来和你说话了。那么马修，西蒙和加芬克尔对非快速眼动睡眠有什么正确的理解？这是最卓越的一种预言般的智慧。我们在白天印刻信息。那种种子在白天就种植在大脑中了。换句话说，我们学习信息。但我们也知道，那颗种植在大脑中的愿景依然留在寂静之声中，在黑夜的黑暗中，正是在那里，深度非快速眼动睡眠
goes to perform its memory functions. Deep non-rem sleep almost hits the save button on those recently acquired informational pieces so that when you wake up the next morning you have remembering rather than forgetting. Non-rem is all about helping us retain information and as we saw from the music of the Rolling Stones and the creation of the periodic table, REM sleep, dream sleep, spurs creativity. But Matthew says, dreams also have another function. That function seems to be about emotional therapy or what I would describe as overnight therapy. Dream sleep provides a fascinating neurochemical soothing balm. It is during dream sleep and only during dream sleep
专门去执行它的记忆功能。深度非快速眼动睡眠几乎按下了那些最近获得的信息片段的保存键，以便你在第二天早上醒来时是记住而不是忘记。非快速眼动睡眠完全是为了帮助我们保留信息，正如我们从滚石乐队的音乐和元素周期表的创造中所看到的，快速眼动睡眠，即梦境睡眠，能激发创造力。但马修说，梦还有另一个功能。这个功能似乎关乎情感疗愈，或者我所描述的夜间疗愈。梦境睡眠提供了一种迷人的神经化学舒缓膏。正是在梦境睡眠期间，而且唯有在梦境睡眠
when our brain shuts off a stress-related neurochemical called Nora Drenlin. Now, it's sister chemical, everyone will be familiar with in the body, that's called a Drenlin. And it's during dream sleep that that chemical is actually shut off. But what we also know is that the emotional and memory centers of the brain during dream sleep
期间，我们的大脑才会关闭一种与压力相关的神经化学物质，叫做去甲肾上腺素。现在，它的姊妹化学物质大家在身体里都很熟悉，叫做肾上腺素。正是在梦境睡眠期间，这种化学物质实际上被关闭了。但我们同样知道的是，在大脑中，情感和记忆中心在梦境睡眠期间
light up in terms of their activity. And so we've proposed that dream sleep provides this perfect opportunity where we can start to reactivate and replay painful, difficult emotional experiences. and replay painful, difficult emotional experiences, but we do so in a neurochemically quote unquote safe environment. And we now understand that dream sleep actually helps separate and strip away that painful emotional sting from those informational experiences so that you wake up feeling better about it. BELL RINGS But what about bad dreams? Hi, I'm Greta Pitinger. Greta is a researcher at NPR,
其活动会被点亮。因此我们提出，梦境睡眠提供了一个绝佳的机会，我们可以开始重新激活和重演痛苦的、困难的情感经历。并重演痛苦、困难的情感经历，但我们是在一个神经化学意义上所谓的安全环境中这样做的。我们现在了解到，梦境睡眠实际上有助于将那种痛苦的情感刺痛从那些信息经验中分离并剥离出来，这样你醒来时感觉会更好。铃声响起 但噩梦呢？嗨，我是格雷塔·皮廷格。格雷塔是 NPR 的一名研究员，
and about eight or nine years ago, her relationship with sleep changed. I let her tell you the story. I had been dating a guy who is now my husband, but at the time we were just dating. He wrote a motorcycle and that was his only form of transportation. So whenever I'd go out with him or he'd drive me to work or something, I would ride on the back and had my own helmet and stuff. Late one night we were coming home from a party and we were in downtown Seattle. Streets were pretty empty but we were going pretty slow coming out of a stop light and
大约八九年前，她与睡眠的关系改变了。我让她给你讲讲这个故事。我当时在和一个现在成为我丈夫的男生交往，但当时我们只是在约会。他骑摩托车，那是他唯一的交通工具。所以每当我跟他出去或者他开车送我去上班之类的时候，我都会坐在后座上，我有自己的头盔什么的。一天深夜，我们从一个派对回家，当时在西雅图市中心。街道相当空旷，但我们刚过红绿灯时车速相当慢，
a large white SUV, Ranna Red Light and crashed into us from the left side. The next thing I remember is waking up on my back in like a elevated planter kind of off on the side of the sidewalk. You know, there's like the street on one side and then the other side has like a little kind of retaining wall with like plants and ferns. And so I was kind of halfway into that. It was about I had flown off the bike and hit my right thigh on that concrete planter and broke the femur like right and half. And when I woke
一台大型白色 SUV 闯红灯，从左侧撞上了我们。我记得的下一件事是醒来时躺在背上，就像在人行道旁边的一个高起的花坛里一样。你知道，就像一边是街道，另一边有一堵小挡土墙，上面有植物和蕨类植物。所以我当时有一半身体陷在里面。大约是——我从车上飞出去，右大腿撞到了那个混凝土花坛上，大腿骨直接断成了两半。当我醒来
up out on my back with my legs kind of dangling and there was flames around me. And then like that's when I think I saw my then boyfriend Joey on the sidewalk and it was like he was also injured separately but didn't have much time to think about any of those things because luckily the police station was two blocks away. And so then police were the first people there and then came and dragged this out. The actual crash of the car had punctured the motorcycle and then the first sound I really remember was an explosion.
躺在背上，双腿有点悬空，周围有火焰。然后就像那时我好像看到我的前男友乔伊在人行道上，他好像也受了伤，但没有太多时间去想这些事情，因为幸运的是警察局就在两个街区外。所以警察是第一批到达那里的人，然后过来把我们拉出来。汽车真正的撞击刺破了摩托车，然后我真正记得的第一个声音是一声爆炸。
Of the motorcycle tank blowing up which was... yeah I don't trust my memories of how intense it was but it was very very scary. Joey actually broke the other femur. He broke his left femur from the impact of the car. I broke my right femur from hitting that wall. He also broke a few other bones. So I stayed in the hospital for maybe four days after surgery. And he stayed for, I want to say at least a full week, maybe 10 days, because you had a couple surgeries. I didn't sleep pretty much at all. Partially because of the painkillers, but I think also that's when bad dreams were starting
摩托车油箱炸裂了，那是……是的，我不相信我对当时情况有多激烈的记忆，但非常非常可怕。乔伊其实断了另一条腿。由于汽车的撞击，他断了左大腿骨。我因为撞到那堵墙断了右大腿骨。他还断了其他几根骨头。所以我手术后在医院住了大概四天。他住了，我想说至少整整一周，也许 10 天，因为你做了几次手术。我几乎根本没睡着。部分原因是因为止痛药，但我也觉得那是噩梦开始的时候，
and I couldn't stop reliving that moment of the crash. I'm not sure if I had these exact dreams in the hospital, but for a couple of years after all of this, I would just keep having dreams about things crashing into me or things running over me. And then specifically that moment also when that car hit us. I would keep going back to that and I remember waking up with a start. You know, like when you wake up suddenly and sometimes you can't remember why, but you know you feel like you fell.
我无法停止重新经历撞车的那一刻。我不确定我是否在医院里做了这些确切的梦，但在这一切发生后的好几年里，我总是不断梦到有东西撞向我或者有东西碾过我。然后尤其是汽车撞击我们的那一刻。我会不断回到那个场景，我记得我是惊醒的。你知道，就像当你突然醒来时，有时你想不起原因，但你知道你感觉自己好像在下坠。
Like you feel like you just fell into bed, that feeling. I like to write and I've kept a journal since I was in fourth grade. I had written about it right after it happened. I had my mom's insistence. I was staying with her, my dad, at the time, and it's just like, I'd wake up from my nap just bawling. She said like you know maybe you should just write it down and let it go. Kind of hoping that might help and I think it did for
就像你感觉自己刚刚掉进床里一样，那种感觉。我喜欢写作，从四年级起我就一直在写日记。事情发生后不久我就写下了这件事。在母亲的坚持下。我当时和她以及我父亲住在一起，这就像是，我从午睡中醒来时嚎啕大哭。她说，你知道，也许你应该把它写下来然后放手。有点希望这会有所帮助，我想它确实起作用了
a little bit but then it kept coming back and I tried to avoid it. When we were talking about dreams some time ago Matthew you said that one of the motorcycle tech. When we were talking about dreams some time ago Matthew, you said that one of the potential virtues of dreams is that they might allow us to relive or experience things that happen to us or things that might happen to us in a relatively safe space. And as we do this, we process what happened and then potentially learn from it. What about nightmares though? Nightmares are not pleasant.
一会儿，但后来它又不断卷土重来，我试图避开它。不久前我们讨论梦的时候，马修，你说过摩托车技术的一个潜在优点……不久前我们讨论梦的时候，马修，你说过梦的一个潜在优点是它们可能允许我们在一个相对安全的空间里重温或体验发生在我们身上的事情或者可能发生在我们身上的事情。当我们这样做时，我们处理发生的事情，然后有可能从中吸取教训。不过噩梦呢？噩梦并不愉快。
They can be disruptive. They can actually be acutely painful. And certainly in Greta's case, they were disruptive to her life. Why would the brain be designed to have nightmares? It's not clear whether the brain actually is designed to have nightmares or whether this is actually the process going awry.
它们可能是破坏性的。它们实际上可能是剧烈痛苦的。当然在格雷塔的案例中，它们扰乱了她的生活。为什么大脑会被设计成会做噩梦呢？目前还不清楚大脑是否真的被设计成会做噩梦，或者这实际上是运作出了岔子的大脑过程。
And we think it may be the latter because when we look at patients, for example, who have post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD, repetitive nightmares are actually so reliable in those patients that they actually form part of the diagnostic criteria for that disorder itself. What we think is happening in the case of PTSD is that that chemical that we spoke about that normally is shut off during dream sleep, the chemical noradrenaline, remains too high. And it may be that when that
我们认为可能是后一种情况，因为当我们观察患有创伤后应激障碍或 PTSD 的患者时，例如，这些患者的重复性噩梦实际上非常稳定，以至于它们成为了该障碍诊断标准本身的一部分。我们认为在 PTSD 的情况下发生的事情是，我们谈到的那种在做梦睡眠期间通常会关闭的化学物质，即去甲肾上腺素，仍然保持在过高的水平。而当这种
chemical is too high in its concentration, we can't gift ourselves that normal therapeutic benefit that REM sleep provides, so that the dreams themselves become particularly emotionally strong and difficult, and you don't get that resolution the next day. And so the process steps and repeats and it happens time and time again. And it is perhaps only when there is some degree of contextualization, be it by way of medication that is now given to certain PTSD, war veterans, for example, drugs out there that seem to help lower that chemical, that stress related chemical, give them normal dream sleep and it gives
化学物质的浓度过高时，我们就无法给自己带来快速眼动睡眠所提供的正常治疗益处，因此梦境本身会变得特别具有强烈的情绪且难以处理，而且第二天你也无法得到这种解决。于是这个过程一步步重复，一次又一次地发生。也许只有在某种程度的语境化之后，比如通过现在给予某些 PTSD 战争老兵的药物，例如那些似乎有助于降低这种化学物质、压力相关化学物质的药物，给他们正常的做梦睡眠，并赋予他们
them back that ability to process those events. That's one way to help. Another is that perhaps by journaling it and going through that process of shifting the context or reformulating it in one's mind, it becomes less stressful. In fact, this is exactly what Greta discovered herself to. In fact, this is exactly what Greta discovered herself to. So, about two or three years after the crash, I was finally seeing a psychiatrist about the kind of lasting trauma and trying to get over that and trying to sleep. I mean, I was trying to help my insomnia as well. And we talked about those dreams. And he knew I like to write.
处理这些事件的能力。这是一种提供帮助的方法。另一种方法可能是通过写日记并经历改变语境或在脑海中重新构建的过程，让它变得压力没那么大。事实上，这正是格雷塔自己发现的。事实上，这正是格雷塔自己发现的。所以，在大约车祸两三年后，我终于去看了一位心理医生，关于那种持久的创伤，试图克服它并试着睡觉。我的意思是，我也在试图帮助我的失眠。我们谈到了那些梦。他知道我喜欢写作。
And so he suggested in my journal just rewriting that dream. Because it's a dream, it's not reality. And so it doesn't need to mimic reality. So just change it. The way I changed that dream was that instead of a car coming and hitting the motorcycle, the motorcycle transformed into a winged horse and flew away. Away from the car, away from all that crash, and then just landed safely back at our apartment, dropped us off.
所以他建议我在日记里重写那个梦。因为那是一个梦，它不是现实。所以它不需要模仿现实。所以只要改变它就好了。我改变那个梦的方式是，没有车子开过来撞到摩托车，而是那摩托车变成了一匹长着翅膀的马飞走了。飞离汽车，飞离所有的车祸，然后安全地降落在我们的公寓，把我们放下。
And so, writing about it again years later, but in a totally different way, not trying to be accurate, not trying to remember, was much different. It definitely got me to stop having those vivid dreams. I've had flying dreams in the past, but I started to have more types of those dreams of kind of being lifted away from gravity and from the weight of these emotions, you know, like when you wake up from a dream
所以，多年后再次写下它，但用一种完全不同的方式，不试图去力求准确，不试图去回忆，有很大的不同。它确实让我不再做那些生动的梦。我过去也做过飞行的梦，但我开始做更多那种被从重力以及这些情绪的沉重感中托举开来的梦，你知道，就像当你从梦中醒来时
and it doesn't really leave a mark on you, that was a good feeling to him. Like, oh yeah, I guess I did have that dream. Oh yeah, that was nice. Just like this past month, Joey and I bought Moe Peds, which is like something he used to do before he even had a motorcycle and I have never ridden before and I'm like, I feel like something he used to do before he even had a motorcycle. And I have never ridden before. And I'm like, I feel like such a badass on this little like,
它并没有真正在你身上留下痕迹，那对他来说是一种很好的感觉。就像，哦，是的，我想我确实做了那个梦。哦，是的，那挺好的。就像上个月，乔伊和我买了电动踏板车，这就像他以前甚至在有摩托车之前常做的事，而我以前从没骑过，我就觉得，我觉得自己骑着这个小东西像个狠角色，
like it's such a dorky little thing. It's like half bike with a tiny engine on it. And it sounds like super high pitched and has the dorkiest horn. But it's like, yeah, look how cool I am. I have to wear a full face helmet. Hahaha. I have to wear a full face helmet. When we come back, we look at the amazing range of things a good night's sleep can accomplish. You know, sleep is the swissohami knife of health.
就像这是一个非常书呆子气的小东西。它就像半辆自行车，带有一个微型发动机。而且它听起来音调超级高，还有最书呆子气的喇叭。但它就像是，是的，看我多酷。我得戴全盔。哈哈哈哈。我得戴全盔。当我们回来时，我们将探讨一个晚上的好睡眠能够完成的惊人范围的事情。你知道，睡眠是健康的瑞士军刀。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is NPR. Welcome back to Hidden Brain I'm Shankar Vedantam. I'm speaking with Matthew Walker, he's a professor of neuroscience and psychology at UC Berkeley, and he's the author of the book Why We Sleep. So let's talk just for a bit about the amount of sleep that people need. You and many other experts say people should strive to get eight hours of sleep every night. To tell you the truth, I got about six hours last night and I feel fine. Tell me where you live.
你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是 NPR。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我正在与加州大学伯克利分校的神经科学和心理学教授马修·沃克对话，他也是《我们为什么要睡觉》一书的作者。所以让我们花一点时间聊聊人们需要的睡眠量。你和许多其他专家都说人们应该努力每说每晚获得八小时的睡眠。老实说，我昨晚只睡了大约六个小时，我感觉很好。告诉我你住在哪里。
I'm coming around tonight. We will have a sleep so long, a sleep so I will inflict change no matter what. Here's my question Matthew. If I can get away with sleeping 25% less than the recommended amount one night, why can't I do it every night? And just think of the upside, I can spend two hours every day reading wonderful books like yours, building a better podcast, being more productive, surely it's a good thing. If we didn't need eight hours of sleep and we could survive on six, Mother Nature would have done away with 25% of our sleep time millions of years ago.
我今晚要过去。我们会睡那么久，无论如何我都会引发改变。这是我的问题，马修。如果我有一个晚上可以比建议的睡眠量少睡 25% 而侥幸过关，为什么我不能每天晚上都这么做？想想看好处，我每天可以花两个小时阅读像你这样精美的书，建立一个更好的播客，变得更有生产力，这肯定是一件好事。如果我们不需要八小时的睡眠，而且我们可以靠六个小时生存，大自然在几百万年前就会把我们 25% 的睡眠时间取消掉了。
Because when you think about it, sleep is an idiotic thing to do. You're not finding a mate, you're not reproducing, you're not finding food, you're not caring for your young, we're still, you're vulnerable. So as it's been said before, if sleep does not provide a remarkable set of benefits, then it's the biggest mistake the evolutionary process has ever made. And it didn't make a spectacular blunder in putting in place through 3.6 million years of evolution, this thing called an eight-hour sleep need. You know, I remember one's going to a talk that showed the level of light pollution on the planet,
因为当你仔细想想，睡觉是一件愚蠢的事情。你没有在寻找伴侣，你没有在繁衍后代，你没有在寻找食物，你没有在照顾你的幼崽，更糟糕的是，你很脆弱。正如以前所说的那样，如果睡眠不能提供一组非凡的好处，那么它就是进化史上犯下的最大错误。而且它在经历 3.6 万年演化过程中，建立起这种称为八小时睡眠需求的机制时，并没有犯下惊人的大错。你知道，我记得有人曾去听过一个讲座，展示了地球上光污染的水平，
the parts of the planet where there were the highest levels of artificial light. Then the researcher took the image off the screen and replaced it with an image showing the distribution of prostate cancer around the world. There was a remarkable correlation between the areas of the world which have light pollution, where presumably people are staying up later and later at night, and presumably getting less sleep than they need, and the incidence of prostate cancer. Now, of course, this is a correlation.
地球上人工光水平最高的那些部分。然后研究人员将图像从屏幕上移开，换成了一张显示世界各地前列腺癌分布的图像。有光污染的地区之间存在着显著的相关性，在这些地区，人们可能在夜间越来越晚睡觉，并且可能得到的睡眠比他们需要的要少，以及前列腺癌的发病率。现在，当然，这是一种相关性。
We don't know if one is connected to the other. But you say there has been some evidence at least that sleep might be implicated in the development of cancer. There is, and it's fast becoming, I think, stronger evidence and causal as well. We know, for example, that one single night of short sleep in these ill-aboratory studies where you perhaps are limited to just four hours of sleep for one single night. The next day, that will draw critical anti-cancer fighting cells called natural killer cells by 70% to 70%. That is an alarming state of
我们不知道其中一个是否与另一个相连。但你说至少有一些证据表明睡眠可能与癌症的发展有关。确实有，而且我认为它正迅速变得越来越强有力且具有因果关系。例如，我们知道，在这些实验室研究中，短短一个晚上的少睡眠，你可能在一个晚上仅限于仅仅四个小时的睡眠。第二天，那会将被称为自然杀伤细胞的关键抗癌细胞减少 70% 到 70%。那是一种令人惊恐的
immune deficiency, and it happens quickly after essentially just one bad night of sleep. We also know from the associational evidence that insufficient sleep is linked to cancer of the bowel, cancer of the prostate, and cancer of the breast. And the link between a lack of sleep and cancer has since become so strong that the World Health Organization has now classified any form of nighttime shift work as a probable cast-synogen. In other words, jobs that may induce cancer because of a disruption of your sleep weight rhythms. Forkvina, the ha-net-ar-baite man or a villoman adhian urese kufa boiskraft.
免疫缺陷状态，而且在基本上经历仅仅一个糟糕的睡眠之夜后就会迅速发生。我们还从关联证据中知道，睡眠不足与肠癌、前列腺癌和乳腺癌有关。缺乏睡眠与癌症之间的联系后来变得如此强烈，以至于世界卫生组织现在已将任何形式的夜间轮班工作分类为可能的致癌物。换句话说，由于破坏你的睡眠觉醒节律而可能诱发癌症的工作。由于无法识别的语言，这部分略过。译者注：此处原音频疑似为听不清的非英语词汇或错误乱码。
In British Grona Surin, Denmark, based on the strength of the evidence that we were just discussing, became the first country to actually pay worker compensation to women who had developed breast cancer after years of nighttime shift working government sponsor jobs I think automation is going to help I think with this revolution of technology Where we can start to limit that type of shift work whenever possible We should absolutely do that and start to scale it back. We can also architect professions better, I think. We know
在丹麦的格陵兰岛，根据我们刚才讨论的证据的力度，成为第一个真正向在政府赞助的工作中经过多年的夜间轮班工作后患上乳腺癌的女性支付工伤赔偿的国家。我认为自动化会有所帮助，我认为随着这项技术的革命，我们可以开始尽可能限制这种轮班工作，我们绝对应该这样做并开始缩减它。我认为我们也可以更好地规划职业。我们知道
that people are genetically predisposed to being night time people or morning people. Why don't we think about asking those questions and seeing if we can help people sort of fit what we call the chronotype, which is the morningness or eveningness propensity, fit that into the job flexibility in those work hours and see if there's some overlap. When you were a kid, your family took a vacation to Greece, and then when you visited Greece again as an adult, you noticed a very big change. What was it? Back in the 1980s when I went on
人们在基因上倾向于成为夜猫子或早起鸟。为什么我们不考虑提出这些问题，看看我们是否能帮助人们适应我们所谓的昼夜节律类型，也就是早起或晚睡的倾向，将这种倾向融入工作灵活性和这些工作时间中，看看是否存在某种重叠。当你还是个孩子的时候，你的家人去希腊度假，然后当你成年后再次访问希腊时，你注意到一个非常大的变化。那是什么？回到 20 世纪 80 年代，我去
on holiday there, there were signs in the shop store windows that would give the opening hours and they would open from between sort of 10 to 2 and then it said closed between 2-4 or 2-5pm and then open from 5-10-11 in the evening. And it was so different to the way in which shops back in England would operate. Maybe there was a 1 hour lunch break or a half hour lunch break, but for the most part it was 9-5 hours classic. And of course what it was describing was this classic CESTA-like behaviour. Now, back in the mid-1990s,
那里度假时，商店的橱窗里会有告示牌，给出营业时间，他们大约在 10 点到 2 点之间营业，然后上面写着下午 2-4 点或 2-5 点闭店，然后从傍晚 5-10-11 点营业。这与英国商店的运营方式非常不同。也许有一个小时的午餐休息时间或半小时的午餐休息时间，但大多数情况下是经典的 9 到 5 点。当然，它所描述的就是这种经典的类似午睡的行为。现在，回到 20 世纪 90 年代中期，
the Greek culture actually started to abandon the CESTA-like practice. And unfortunately, or unfortunately, a group of scientists from Harvard University School of Public Health decided to quantify the health consequences of this radical change in sleep practice. And with many Greek tragedies, as was the case here, the results were heartbreaking, but in the most literal sense, what they actually observed was a 37% increase risk for death from heart attacks across that
希腊文化实际上开始放弃这种类似午睡的习俗。不幸的是，或者说不幸的是，来自哈佛大学公共卫生学院的一群科学家决定量化睡眠习惯这一根本性变化对健康的后果。正如许多希腊悲剧一样，这里的情况也是如此，结果令人心碎，但从最字面意义上讲，他们实际观察到的是，由于取消了那种午睡行为，
six-year period as a consequence of doing away with that CES to behaviour. It was actually particularly strong in working males, almost a 60% increased risk of death from heart attacks. So I think that that again suggests not only how important sleep is and when sleep is taken away, we see this type of danger to our cardiovascular health. It raises actually a different question which is how should we be sleeping? Because the way that we currently try to sleep is what's called monophysics sleep, where we sleep one single about throughout the night. But if you look at some cultures who are untouched by electricity, sort of hunt together at tribes, for example, they actually tend to sleep by-phasically. They tend to sleep for
在六年期间，死于心脏病的风险增加了 37%。在工作的男性中，这种风险尤其强烈，死于心脏病的风险增加了近 60%。所以我认为这再次表明了睡眠是多么重要，当睡眠被剥夺时，我们会看到这种对心血管健康的危害。这实际上提出了一个不同的问题，那就是我们应该如何睡觉？因为我们目前试图睡觉的方式被称为单相睡眠，也就是我们在整夜中只睡单单一觉。但是如果你看看一些未受电网影响的文化，例如某种狩猎采集部落，他们实际上往往进行双相睡眠。他们往往会睡
sort of six, seven hours at night, then they'll have a CS Delight nap in the afternoon. And it turns out that we all have this in us. It is genetically hard-wired that we all have a pre-programmed drop in our alertness, some time after lunch. Now many of us think it has to do with the lunch that we have. It's think it has to do with the lunch that we have, it's actually not, you can stop the lunch and you still get it. Which actually does argue from an evolutionary perspective that we should be sleeping by basically,
大约六、七个小时的觉，然后在下午小睡一会儿。事实证明，我们所有人体内都有这个。它是基因硬编码的，我们所有人都有一个预编程的警觉性下降，在午餐后的一段时间。现在我们很多人认为这与我们吃的午餐有关。人们认为这与我们吃的午餐有关，实际上并非如此，你可以不吃午餐，你仍然会有这种感觉。这实际上从进化论的角度主张我们应该进行双相睡眠，
rather than monophasically, two bouts of sleep rather than one, perhaps. I have to say, Matthew, that in some ways, when it comes to sleep, there's almost a sense of people bragging about not getting enough sleep, right? I mean, it's that in some ways when it comes to sleep there's almost a sense of people bragging about not getting enough sleep, right? I mean, it's certainly in the United States. It's seen as a badge of honor to say, you know, I get very little sleep because I'm so productive and I work so hard and I achieve so much. Oh, you're so you're so right because what we've done is actually stigmatized sleep. We label people who get sufficient sleep,
而不是单相睡眠，也许是两段睡眠而不是一段。我必须说，马修，在某些方面，当谈到睡眠时，人们几乎有一种在吹嘘自己睡眠不足的感觉，对吧？我的意思是，在某些方面，当谈到睡眠时，人们几乎有一种在吹嘘自己睡眠不足的感觉，对吧？我的意思是，当然在美国。说“我睡眠很少，因为我很有生产力，我工作很努力，我取得了很大的成就”被视为一种荣誉的徽章。哦，你太对了，因为我们实际上对睡眠进行了污名化。我们将那些获得充足睡眠的人，
and I choose that word very carefully, with being lazy, with being slothful, and that is a terrible disservice to society. And we don't always have that opinion, by the way. You know, no one looks at an infant sleeping during the day and says, pfft, what a lazy baby. And we don't, you know, and we laugh, but we don't because we know that sleep at that
我非常仔细地选择这个词，贴上了懒惰、散漫的标签，这对社会是一个巨大的伤害。顺便说一句，我们并不总是持有这种观点。你知道，没有人看着白天睡觉的婴儿说，呸，真是个懒惰的婴儿。而且我们没有，你知道，我们笑了，但我们没有，因为我们知道那个
time of life is non-negotiable. It's absolutely necessary. But now, even into early childhood, not only do we abandon the notion that sleep is important and should be celebrated, we chastise people for getting sufficient sleep and give them this label. Tell me about your own sleep habits and tell me what you do to ensure you get a good night's rest. I'm going to sound like a desperate prude and I'm so sorry and it sounds hokey as well but I actually give myself a non-negotiable eight-hour sleep opportunity every night.
人生阶段的睡眠是不可协商的。它是绝对必要的。但现在，甚至在幼儿期，我们不仅放弃了睡眠很重要且应该被庆祝的观念，我们还因为人们获得了充足睡眠而责备他们，并给他们贴上这个标签。跟我讲讲你自己的睡眠习惯，以及你做些什么来确保自己能睡个好觉。我听起来会像个绝望的伪君子，我真的很抱歉，而且听起来也很老套，但我实际上每天晚上都给自己一个不可协商的八小时睡眠机会。
Do you try and stick to very rigid hours when sleeping at the same time, waking up at the same time, do you use an alarm clock, do you avoid technology before you go to sleep? I do so, I stop checking my email at a certain time, I have software installed on my computers that does away with the harmful blue light and I shut them off at least an hour and a half before bed. But you mentioned perhaps the single most important sleep prescription that I could give everyone which is regularity. Just go to bed at the same time, wake up at the same time no matter what, whether it's the weekday or the weekend, if you've had a good night of sleep or a bad night of sleep, stay as regular as you can. That's the best piece of advice I can give you for getting good sleep at night.
你会试图坚持非常严格的睡眠时间吗，在同一时间睡觉，在同一时间醒来，你用闹钟吗，你在睡觉前避开科技产品吗？我确实这么做，我在某个时间停止检查电子邮件，我的计算机上安装了软件，可以消除有害的蓝光，并且我在睡觉前至少一个半小时关闭它们。但你提到了我能给每个人的也许是最重要的睡眠处方，那就是规律性。无论是在工作日还是周末，无论是你昨晚睡得好还是睡得不好，都要在同一时间睡觉，在同一时间醒来，无论如何，尽可能保持规律。这是我能给你的关于晚上获得良好睡眠的最好建议。
Matthew Walker is a professor of neuroscience and psychology at the University of California at Berkeley. He said he's sleep and he's the author of the book, Why We Sleep. Matthew, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. You're very welcome. Thank you very much and I do hope you sleep well tonight. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Parts Shah and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Reina Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu and Laura Quarell. Our intern is Camilla Vargas Restrepo. NPR's Vice President for Programming is Anya Grunman. I'm Shankar Vidantum. I hope you have sweet dreams tonight. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
马修·沃克是加州大学伯克利分校的神经科学和心理学教授。他说他是睡眠专家，并且是《我们为什么要睡觉》一书的作者。马修，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。不客气。非常感谢，我确实希望你今晚能睡个好觉。本期《隐藏的大脑》由帕茨·沙阿制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、珍妮·施密特、托马斯·刘和劳拉·夸雷尔。我们的实习生是卡米拉·巴尔加斯·雷斯特雷波。NPR 节目副总裁是阿尼亚·格伦曼。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。希望你今晚有个甜蜜的梦。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。